Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Esta es una planta de tomate,
Y este es un áfido que mata lentamente
la planta de tomate
chupando el jugo de sus hojas.
El tomate está activando una lucha
usando defensas físicas y químicas
para repeler los insectos atacantes.
Pero eso no es todo.
El tomate también libera compuestos que
avisan a las plantas de tomate cercanas
para que liberen su propio
repelente de insectos.
Las plantas están
constantemente bajo ataque.
Se enfrentan a amenazas que van desde
hongos microscópicos y bacterias,
pequeños herbívoros, como áfidos,
orugas y saltamontes,
hasta grandes herbívoros,
como tortugas, koalas y elefantes.
Todos buscan devorar plantas
para acceder a los abundantes nutrientes
y agua en sus hojas,
tallos, frutos y semillas.
Pero las plantas están listas con toda
una serie de defensas internas y externas
que las hacen una comida
mucho menos atractiva,
o incluso mortal.
Las defensas de las plantas
comienzan en su superficie.
La corteza que cubre los troncos de
los árboles está llena de lignina,
una tela rígida de compuestos
que es difícil de masticar
y altamente impermeable a los patógenos.
Las hojas están protegidas
por una cutícula cerosa
que disuade a insectos y microbios.
Algunas plantas van un paso más allá
con estructuras dolorosas
para advertir a
los posibles depredadores.
Puyas, espinas y púas
desalientan a los herbívoros más grandes.
Para plagas pequeñas, las hojas de algunas
plantas tienen estructuras como pelos
llamados tricomas.
La planta de fríjol tiene pequeños ganchos
para herir los pies de los chinches
y otros insectos.
En algunas especies, los tricomas
también liberan irritantes químicos.
Las ortigas liberan una mezcla de
histamina y otras toxinas
que causan dolor e inflamación
cuando se tocan.
En otras especies de plantas,
el dolor viene luego
del primer mordisco del herbívoro.
Espinacas,
kiwi
piña,
fucsia y el ruibarbo
todas producen cristales microscópicos
en forma de aguja llamados rafides.
Pueden causar pequeñas heridas
en el interior de la boca de los animales,
que crean puntos de entrada
para las toxinas.
La planta de mimosa tiene una estrategia
diseñada para prevenir del todos
que los herbívoros la muerdan.
Células mecanorreceptoras
especializadas detectan el tacto
y disparan una señal eléctrica
a través de la hoja a su base
haciendo que las células
liberen partículas cargadas.
La acumulación de carga
extrae agua de estas células
y se marchitan,
haciendo que las hojas se plieguen.
El movimiento de plegado
asusta a los insectos
y las hojas encogidas parecen menos
atractivas a los animales más grandes.
Si estas defensas externas son superadas
el sistema inmunológico de la planta
entra en acción.
Las plantas no tienen un sistema inmune
separado como los animales.
En cambio, cada célula tiene la capacidad
de detectar y defenderse de los invasores.
Receptores especializados pueden reconocer
moléculas que señalan la presencia
de microbios o insectos peligrosos.
En respuesta, el sistema inmune inicia
una batería de maniobras defensivas.
Para evitar que más patógenos
hagan camino hacia dentro,
la cutícula cerosa se espesa y las
paredes celulares se hacen más fuertes.
Las células de guardia
sellan poros en las hojas.
Y si los microbios devoran
una sección de la planta,
esas células pueden autodestruirse
para poner en cuarentena la infección.
También se producen compuestos
tóxicos para microbios e insectos,
a menudo hechos a medida
para una amenaza específica.
Muchas de las moléculas vegetales
que los humanos han adoptado
como medicamentos, medicinas y condimentos
evolucionaron como parte de los
sistemas inmunes de las plantas
porque son antimicrobianos o insecticidas.
Un área de una planta bajo ataque puede
alertar a otras regiones usando hormonas,
compuestos aerotransportados
o incluso señales eléctricas.
Cuando otras partes de la planta
detectan estas señales,
aumentan la producción
de compuestos defensivos.
Y en algunas especies, como los tomates,
este sistema de alerta temprana
también alerta a sus vecinos.
Algunas plantas incluso pueden reclutar
aliados para adoptar una ofensiva fuerte
contra sus posibles atacantes.
Las plantas de algodón
bajo asedio de orugas
lanzan un cóctel específico de diez
a doce productos químicos en el aire.
Esta mezcla atrae las avispas parasitarias
que ponen huevos dentro de las orugas.
Las plantas pueden no ser capaces
de huir de la escena de un ataque
o luchar contra los depredadores
con dientes y garras,
pero con una robusta armadura,
un arsenal químico bien surtido,
un reloj de barrio
y alianzas entre especies,
una planta no siempre es una comida fácil.